your peak you were saying you were
making how much money per year
we look
in the gas business we were bringing and
we were selling half a billion gallons
of gas a month we were taking down 20 30
40 cents a gallon depending upon the
deals we made we're bringing it five
eight million dollars a week
and i was paying up on that but this was
money that i earned
i know there's a lot of bologna around
it all of a sudden uh gas pipe i never
even i never even had to sit down with
gas pipe in the end never never
everybody wants to claim credit for the
gas let me tell you what happened with
the gas there were little guys doing it
some of the russians were involved and
that's some of the russian views are
involved in it i happen to have a guy
larry irishman you know the story we
spoke about it that came to me with a
germ of an idea and we knew how to grow
it into what we grew it in we probably
we
we did the most in that light in that
gas business there's no doubt about it
because everybody came to us
john came to us through vic arena and
tried to get a piece everybody was
trying to get a piece of the action but
the bottom line is we created that
yeah we had a piece without it yeah we
recreated yeah yeah i'm not saying it
was already i said tony pep and other
guys were doing the gas
let me tell my servants
i know guys
from the russians started this they did
not start it that's not true okay that
let me send you annotations everybody's
telling a story because they think they
make it up the russians did not i
brought three russians into the business
with me they couldn't get licensed
gas stock this is all a matter of record
everything i tell you as a matter of
fact
mike markowitz live persons david
bowkerton they had a company called gas
stop
the reason they came to me is because
somebody beat them out of seven thousand
dollars they couldn't collect and they
came to me through somebody i knew i
brought them into the business because
they couldn't get licensed
we expanded big time with
i'm trying to think his name he was a
guy in the genovese family
and he asked john you are you in this
case business
he says that he was making so much money
he didn't even know where to hide it
anymore
and he said i have a girlfriend
that he wasn't even that crazy about
he said i just bought a brand new
mercedes
i was sitting there john said have you
bought him a brand new mercedes
he said john i don't even know where to
put it anymore so i just bought it i
gave it to it's like giving the three
cents to me so there was a lot of guys
in it tony pep was in it and i can't
think of the other guys
and that that other guy i think
i knew something in russia this is the
way i got it from the russians from
other guys who were in it
was another guy
there's no doubt
they told me maybe you could tell me
they were lying but that's okay
because i don't give a [ __ ] i wasn't in
the game
but
they said that the russians are the ones
that invented it what did they do
they came to the united states
and they opened up these companies
gas companies
and they turned around
and they went to the gas companies
and bought the gas
and paid for it
so to guess
i'm going to use a hypothetical number
50 cents a gallon
it becomes a dollar a gallon with the
gears with the tax
so they paid the 50 cents of that gallon
and they got
the case it's painful
so they got to go and get stations
to pump it into the stations
not a station
we make them save 10 cents whatever it
is
and
they pay
the guess and the tax
the gas is already paid
they hold the taxes when it comes time a
year a year and change the tax money is
not being paid to the irs
they start coming around where's the tax
money would you do it they close the
company and they're gone
they're back in [ __ ] russia let me
finish it
and
that's the way it went but here's their
problem
not that they needed your protection or
mine or anybody else's
what their problem is
is that they were smart enough to look
at the italians and the mafia
and conclude
with their connections they have
thousands of gas stations so now we have
it out
we only have 10 people we can convince
or um exaggerate to to do it
but now we can go to them make believe
we're scared
and look for their protection and we're
going to make them make money
but they got to give us stations as well
that's what i heard it's okay and
totally
and i don't mean a total nonsense okay i
suppose i said i wasn't in that
you told it
incorrectly but you told it in reverse
russians weren't buying gas none of that
what happened originally you can go back
and see
the tax was being collected at the gas
station level you could have been
anybody sitting in his room owned a gas
station being paid attacks
seven eight months later you closed down
somebody else takes over now they got to
pay the tax the government was very slow
in collecting they were antiquated
what happened we had irizo had a small
company called vantage petroleum that's
what he was doing he had different
people he installed in gas stations and
they'd run the company they run the gas
station for a couple of months when the
government finally came down they
disappear a month later new guys take
somewhere now the government thinks they
get smart
they say we're not going to collect at
the gas station level anymore we're
going to require you to be a licensed
wholesaler you got to get licensed
russians couldn't get licenses
we were able to get licenses to get
connection but here's what happened then
they started collecting at the wholesale
level where the wholesaler collected the
tax and we were responsible to pay the
government i had 18 different companies
that were licensed to collect the tax
nobody else had that because we had a
connection to get the license we had
companies that were using out of panama
and let me tell you let me let me give
let me give i arizona he was brilliant
in how he figured out the scheme i just
helped him expand it and do what i had
to do and go away was the job
john and you were talking about
doing the gas or whatever
was this before castellano or f
it was before that was before yeah
he was doing guests
after
castle
after and you were gone yes and so was
this guy
i could get his name but i can't think
of it in the geneves family
and i know other people who were doing
it i was never in it
when i even thought about doing it john
said we got tony pep
uh again i can't think of the other
guy's name they're doing it for us and
everybody in his mind is making money
there was even people in uh providence
who were doing it there's a problem with
all of that though
i went away because irizzo who created a
big part of the scheme became an
informant and he's the guy that told
everybody i know he's a guy that told
everybody but the bottom line when i
first got involved
and again this comes to the money and
power i went to junior
when i realized what i had and i said
junior
i'm going to show you more money than
you ever saw before he immediately said
no drugs we don't deal in drugs i said
junior i hate drugs you know that i
don't want to get into that we don't
deal with drugs i said it's gas
i said but here's what's going to happen
i says i got a guy he's pretty smart i
believe in what he's doing i said but
everybody and their brother is going to
want to get into this i didn't have the
russians at that moment i said everybody
and their brother is going to want to
get into this when that happens we're
going to get destroyed i said because
everybody's going to mess it up i said
you got to protect me you got to make me
win every argument you can't let anybody
get involved if you do that i'll show
you more money than you ever saw before
he said show me and i'll join you you
don't talk show me
i was bringing him two million dollars a
week
and that bought a lot of loyalty and
when john and the reason the reason i
had a problem with vicarina i know we're
going to talk about that is because
vic teamed up with john to come against
me to get a piece of the gas business
both i don't i don't know yeah he did
this was in 81 82 around there and it
didn't happen because they were trying
to get me to service them and
i said junior if you're going to give
these guys credit then you're
responsible to collect i said because
i'm not going to go through that because
gas in the ground is like money it
turned out the next day you got cash you
got a couple of million dollars of gas
in the ground that's money same thing
absolutely
so we kept them out
but
it wasn't the russians we brought the
russians in somewhere
it was afterwards
i did time with one of the russians yeah
i can't i can't speak for what happened
afterwards i know my three russians were
destroyed because iris who gave all
three yeah well they weren't doing that
like you said like you were doing with
the gas and i i know you made a lot of
money
but the russians did it again on their
own in a different way and they were
hooked all over the place the fbi blamed
me for teaching your government teaching
the russians how to defraud the fbi
blamed you yeah they blame me they said
because now from the guest business they
went into the health business and
they're taking money left and right in
the healthcare scams and it's all the
russians and armenians i believe these
armenians seriously it's just
no that's what they told me they took me
out to california and said see all these
all the armenians running they're
scamming like crazy i said and they said
you taught him how to do it
don't blame me but the armenians
you